ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH.
BONTA BRO. BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN
DAVID CHIU CHOI. KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY DEEP EGGMAN FLORA FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY S. THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO. SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. A WORM
IS PRESENCE WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ONE OF OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND OSHA. REVENUES TO.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. THIS SUNDAY THE SAN
FRANCISCO FORTY NINERS WILL
FACE THE KANSAS CITY CHIEFS IN
SUPER BOWL FIFTY FOUR. IT WILL
BE A GAME LIKE NO OTHER FOR MID
THE JUBILATION FELT BEFORE
EVERY SUPERBOWL. THIS WEEK WE
HAVE BEEN AWAKENED AGAIN TO
WHAT IS REALLY OF VALUE IN LIFE.
THE SHARED PAIN IN DISBELIEF OF
THE FAMILIES DEVASTATED BY THE
HELICOPTER CRASH FIVE DAYS AGO.
HAS OPENED OUR WISDOM ICE. AND
THE LOSS OF KOBE BRYANT AND HIS
DAUGHTER CHIANA HAVE PLACE THIS
TRAGEDY ON AN INTERNATIONAL
STAGE. OUR HEARTS CONTINUE TO
ACHE FOR THE GRIEVING FAMILIES
AND THE SHOCK AND GRIEF
CONTINUES TO RESONATE
PROFOUNDLY BEYOND JUST THE
WORLD OF SPORTS. IN AN
INTERVIEW BEFORE RETIRING COLBY
SAID. I WANT TO BE REMEMBERED
AS A PLAYER THAT NEVER WASTED A
MOMENT THAT NEVER WASTED A DAY.
WE MAY NOT BE WORLD CLASS
ATHLETES BUT WE CAN ALWAYS
STRIVE TO BECOME BETTER HUMAN
BEINGS. WITH WISDOM EYES OPEN
WE KNOW THAT EVERY DAY IS THE
FOURTH QUARTER AND EVERY MOMENT
CAN BE SIGNALING A TWO MINUTE
WARNING. WITH OUR WISDOM EYES
OPEN WE KNOW AGAIN THAT EVERY
MOMENT IS PRECIOUS AND WE MUST
LIVE TRYING OUR VERY BEST TO BE
OUR BEST SELVES EVERYDAY. EVEN
WITH THE SMALLEST OF GESTURES
WE CAN MAKE A POSITIVE
DIFFERENCE IN THE WORLD. WITH
JUST THE CARING SMILE WE CAN
HELP TO MAKE OUR WORLD A BETTER
KINDER PLACE TO LIVE. JUST AS
THE TEAMS AND PLAYERS THIS
SUNDAY WILL BE TRYING TO DO
THEIR VERY BEST. LET US STRIVE
EACH DAY TO BECOME THE BEST
PEOPLE WE CAN BE. NOW MORE ME
THEM WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS. THANK
YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE. IS DO I MEAN OR YOUR
NATION'S FLAG. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO. AND IS. FOR ALL
THANK. THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS
AND PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE TO
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. TODAY'S ABSENCES
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER. FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GRAY
AND SPEAKER RENDON. AND FOR
MATERNITY LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES. MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE DO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS PETRIE-NORRIS
WEBER RUBIO KAMLAGER GABRIEL
GIPSON JONES SAWYER HOLDEN
MCCARTY ENJOYED TO SPEAK ON IN
A GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. MEMBERS WE HAVE
GUESTS WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS-
ALLOW ME TO INTRODUCE THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS UP IN THE
GALLERY IF YOU COULD KINDLY
STAND IN THE GALLERY- ARE
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS AS YOU KNOW
HAVE ALL TAKEN PROACTIVE STEPS
TO PROMOTE PATIENT SAFETY. AS
WELL AS INCREASED EDUCATION
ABOUT PAIN MANAGEMENT SAKE OF
YOUR USE AND THE NON OPIOID
ALTERNATIVES TO PAIN MANAGEMENT
UP IN THE GALLERY THIS MORNING
IS DOCTOR CHRISTINE DOYLE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ANESTHESIOLOGISTS
WHO ALSO HAVE. A FROM SILICON
VALLEY AND SOME OF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME WALKING INTO
THIS AND WE CHAMBERS.
MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
GOVERNOR'S VETO SHALL BE
CONTINUED. ITEMS ON
RECONSIDERATION. OUR CONTINUED
MOVING TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE. WILL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM ELEVEN AB ONE FIFTY THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE FIFTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER AND ACTUALLY THE
PEOPLE'S. MISTER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
ONE FIFTY REMOVE BARRIERS FOR
FOSTER YOUTH AND OTHER HIGHLY
MOBILE YOUTH AND GRADUATING
FROM HIGH SCHOOL ON TIME IT
WILL HELP ASSURE THEY'RE
SUPPORTED IN ACHIEVING THEIR
ACADEMIC GOALS. THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO APPROVE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATES A POST
SECONDARY OR VACATION-
EDUCATION SUCCESS BY CRYING
THAT SUMMER COURSE WORK
COMPLETED A DIFFERENT SCHOOL
WITH DIFFERENT COURSE TITLES IS
COMBINE TO OUR STUDENTS TO MEET
STATE MINIMUM GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS. ARE SPENT THE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. YEAH. ALL
MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
WORK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY FOUR
NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
TWO THIRTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SANTIAGO AND ACTUALLY TO
VEHICLES. MEMBERS I ASK YOU
GIVE YOUR SPECIAL ATTENTION
YOUR COLLEAGUE MISTER SANTIAGO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I THINK YOU
MEANT SPEAKER AB TWO THIRTY IT
WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET ON A
STRIKE TEAM TAX WITH
IDENTIFYING SHUTTING DOWN
UNLIKE HIS VEHICLE TO CEMENTING
SHOPS- TO YOUR TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU MISTER
SANTIAGO SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERITABLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR
DEBATE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. WORK WILL LOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY VOTE EYES FIFTY
FIVE NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES. WE TO FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHTY THREE
BY SOME REMEMBER CARILLO AND
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL. HISTORY ARE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
PROUD 2% AB SIX EIGHTY THREE A
BILL THAT UPDATES THE OUTDATED
MEDI CAL ASSETS TEST TO ALLOW
SENIORS. ACCESS TO MUCH NEEDED
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. ONCE AN
ADULT TURN SIXTY FIVE OR
BECOMES MEDICARE ELIGIBLE THERE
MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY IS
DETERMINED BY A RESTRICTIVE SET
OF RULES THAT REQUIRE THEM TO
HAVE MINIMAL ASSETS TO REMAIN
ELIGIBLE. THE LIMIT IS TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL AND THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A COUPLE AMOUNTS
THAT HAVE REMAINED UNCHANGED
SINCE I WAS NINE YEARS OLD IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE. THE
UNINTENDED RESULT IS THE PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO REMAIN MEDI CAL
ELIGIBLE ELIGIBLE DEPLETE ALL
OF THE RESOURCES TO CONTINUE
RECEIVING BENEFITS. THE MEDICAL
PROGRAM HAS ALLOWED CERTAIN
EXCLUSIONS TO THE ASSETS TEST
INCLUDING EXCEPTIONS FOR
SOMEONE'S PRIMARY RESIDENCE.
HOWEVER THESE POLICIES ARE
INEQUITABLE- ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING THE DISPARITIES IN
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR EXAMPLE A LOW INCOME SENIOR
WHO OWNS AN EXPENSIVE HOME CAN
QUALIFY FOR MEDI CAL BUT A
RENTER WITH THE SAME INCOME
WILL NOT QUALIFY IF THEY'D HAD.
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE DOLLARS IN
THE BANK AB SIX EIGHTY THREE
WILL UPDATE THESE ASSETS LIMITS
TO THAT TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR PROGRAMS. SERVING SENIORS
AND FIVE THOUSAND FOR
INDIVIDUALS ADDITION FOR EACH
INDIVIDUAL- IN THE HOUSEHOLD.
THE BILL WILL ALSO ELIMINATE
THE ASSETS TEST FOR MEDICARE
SAVINGS PROGRAM PROGRAMS OR
MEDICAL PAYS FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL'S MEDICARE PREMIUMS
AND CO PAYMENTS. THE BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND ALLOWS THAT
SENIORS ACCESS MEDI CAL WITHOUT
HAVING TO DRAMATICALLY SPEND
DOWN THEIR OWN HARD EARNED
SAVINGS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
CARILLO SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. HOME VOTE IS THERE TO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. WE. IS WHERE WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE
FIFTY EIGHT ZERO THIS MEASURE
PASSES BY LIGHT IN FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN BY FAMILY
MEMBER DALY AND ACTUALLY THE
REAL ESTATE MAKING IN
PREPARATION THEREFORE IS YOUR
DAILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS
BILL ALLOWS LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANIES TO BE LICENSES REAL
ESTATE BROKERS SIMPLY AS AN
OPTION. NOT A REQUIREMENT JUST
AN OPTION THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION HAS
REQUESTED THIS OPTIONAL CHOICE
TO PROVIDE BROKERS GREATER
FLEXIBILITY IN DETERMINING
THEIR MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE AND
OPERATIONS AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN CONTACTED
BY LOCAL REALTORS THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AS EXPRESSED CONCERNS
I RESPECT THOSE CONCERNS
GREATLY THEY ARE WORKING
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS SHOULD THE MEASURE
PASS ASSEMBLY FLOOR A IN THE
SENATE I'M COMMITTED REACHING.
ALL OF THE CONCERNS. WILL NOT
MOVE THE MONEY FURTHER IN THIS.
THERE I RESPECTFULLY YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK. MR
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE MATTER. COLLEAGUES IT'S A
PART OF MY LONG HISTORY HERE I
WORKED MANY YEARS IN THE
SHELTER INDUSTRY CLOSE
RELATIONS WITH THE REAL
THERE'S- A OF. I UNDERSTAND
WHAT MAKES WHAT MR DALY IS
SEEKING TO DO I'M SUPPORTIVE OF
IT I WOULD. IN A WAY I CAN
ASSIST THERE'S BEEN SOME CHANGE
IN THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
REALTORS JUST OF LATE. BUT MY
RELATIONS GO BACK WITH THEM FOR
MANY DECADES SELL. HIGHER CHEN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
COOPER MISSED TO DALE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER MISTER DALY WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THEIR OWN. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE A- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. LOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY
ONE NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES MOVING IF FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN AB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN TWENTY FIVE BUY
SOMETHING MEMBER WICKS AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE LAND
USE THIS WICKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER- FUNDAMENTALLY THIS
BILL IS A MISSING MIDDLE
HOUSING BILL THIS WILL CREATE
MORE OPPORTUNITY FOR
HOMEOWNERSHIPAND STABLE
HOUSING FOR MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES. AB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
REQUIRES THAT MUCH YOUR POLICY.
AB SEVENTY FIVE REQUIRES THAT
METROPOLITAN JURISDICTIONS
ALLOCATE 25% OF THEIR ABOVE
MODERATE MODERATE HOUSING TO
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING. THIS IS A
HOUSING PRODUCTION BILL TO GIVE
ZONING FLEXIBILITY TO LOCALS AS
A THOUGHTFUL IMPROVEMENT
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW. CALIFORNIA
NEEDS MORE HOUSING ACROSS THE
BOARD AND DUPLEXES TRI PLEX IS
AND THOUGHTFUL MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING IS ONE OF THE BEST
WAYS. TO INCREASE DENSITY ALSO
HONORING THE FACT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I SPENT MONTHS
THIS FALL WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION ORIGINALLY WE GOT
THEM ALL ON NEUTRAL I WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF IT HAS NO OPPOSITION
WHATSOEVER IT'S SUPPORTED BY
CALIFORNIA BE. A CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IT WAS THE-
BIPARTISAN SUPPORTING MEDIA AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. YES BOERNER HORVATH ARE
RECOGNIZED YES WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT FROM OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
OAKLAND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THIS
BILL PUTS AN UNDUE BURDEN ON
CITIES THIS BILL GOES INTO
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND GIVE CITIES ONLY THREE TO
FOUR MONTHS TO ACTUALLY COMPLY
WITH THEIR NEXT SIX CYCLE
HOUSING ELEMENT UPDATE IT IS
HARD FOR CITIES TO COMPLY WITH
THE MANDATES WE GIVE THEM
SACRAMENTO AND WE SHOULD BE
THINKING TWICE ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING. MOST CITIES HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO IMPLEMENT- THE
DUPLEXES BY THEMSELVES WITHOUT
US MANDATING IT FROM SACRAMENTO
HAVE A PROCESS MY AGE THE D.
CAN DOES IT A CITY HAS ENOUGH
MODERATE ABOVE HOUSE. THEN THIS
BILL ONLY PUT IN A DISH BURDEN
UPON CITIES AND THE ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF. YOU KNOW CERTAIN
VERY URBAN PARTS OF OUR STATE
TRYING TO TELL US WHO ARE NOT
URBAN. THAT WE THEY KNOW BEST
AND I DON'T THINK WE DO KNOW
BASS I THINK WE NEED TO DO AND
RESPECT THE PROCESS THAT WE
HAVE SENT. TO ME SURE THE
CITY'S CAN COMPLY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU DID NOT
VOTE FOR THIS BILL I AM IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MISTER
DAVID CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I WANT TO SPEAK AS A
CHAIR OF THE HOUSING COMMITTEE.
I AND MAKE A FEW POINTS I IN
SUPPORT OF THIS FIRST OF ALL I
APPRECIATE THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
TACKLE THIS VERY IMPORTANT.
CONVERSATION OF HOW WE KNOW
THAT TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE ADDRESS. BOB
IN MEDIUM DENSITY HOUSING.
DUPLEXES FOUR PLEX IS ANOTHER
SIMILAR BUILDINGS THAT FIT WITH
THE NEIGHBORHOOD CHARACTER BUT-
ARE CAN BE AFFORDABLE TO OUR
MIDDLE CLASS. THIS IS A BILL-
THAT THE AUTHOR HAD AGREED TO
HOLD LAST SPRING. AND WORKED
VERY HARD OVER THE LAST SIX
MONTHS TO REMOVE THE OPPOSITION
OF DISPARATE ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION. THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AT THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WITHOUT REMOVING SUPPORT FROM
GROUPS LIKE THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION YEAH BEES AND OTHER
PRO HOUSING. ORGANIZATIONS I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
AUTHOR TOOK NUMEROUS AMENDMENTS
IN OUR COMMITTEE TO FOCUS THE
CHURCH THE FOCUS SPELL. A
PARTICULARLY ON CHANGES WITHIN
METROPOLITAN AND URBAN
DISTRICTS. MORE MARKET FOR
DUPLEXES AND THEIR MEETING
DENSITY. A SOME MORE EDUCATION
FROM. MODERATE TO MODERN INCOME.
RECOGNIZING THIS CHALLENGE
AROUND MIDDLE CLASS AND SO
SAID. APPRECIATE THE OF THE
AUTHOR. I AS YOU BE DISCUSSED
IN OUR COMMITTEE AND WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. SEEING
HEARING FOR THEIR- ON THE
MATTER MR YOU MAKE LOW. THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUE IN ENCINITAS
YOU KNOW EVERY CITIES IN IT AS
A DIFFERENT TIME ONE IN TERMS
OF. THEIR THEIR PROCESS FOR-
DETERMINING THEIR- HOW THEY'RE
GONNA BUILD THE APPROPRIATE
HOUSING THAT WE NEED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES I'M HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM INSTEAD IS TO.
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES AS
THE BILL GOES THROUGH CITY GETS
OFF THE FLOOR TODAY. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE AT CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE AYE AYES FORTY THREE KNOWS
TWENTY THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
FIFTY FIVE BY SOME THE MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND ACTUALLY IN A
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION. THIS
RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THE MATTER MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE OR REQUIRE
CAMPUS AFFILIATED FRATERNITIES
AND SORORITIES TALLY REPORT AND
PUBLICIZE INFORMATION ON
MISCONDUCT AND CITATIONS GRADE
POINT AVERAGE ACTIVE AND YOU
MEMBERS AND MONEY RAISED ON
THEIR SCHOOLS WEBSITES.
COLLEAGUES EVERY EFFORT WE MAKE
TOWARDS INCREASING TRANSPARENCY
ON COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES TO KEEP OUR STUDENTS
SAFE IS A POSITIVE STEP.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
REFINE LANGUAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AS THE BILL MOVED
FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER
RODRIGUEZ SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE I SIXTY NINE NEWS HERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB SIXTEEN
SIXTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SIXTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS MR
LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FANCIED REMEMBERS
AB SIXTEEN SIXTEEN WILL REDUCE
EMPLOYMENT PARRIS FOR PEOPLE
WITH. A PRIOR CRIMINAL RECORDS
WHO HAVE BEEN REHABILITATED AND
WHOSE CONVICTIONS HAVE BEEN
DISMISSED OR EXPUNGE OF
ADDITIONAL PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MISTER LOWE. BEING IN
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY ONE
NEWS HERE THE MEASURE PASSES.
WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND
VIOLATING EIGHTEEN PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
NINETEEN. MOVING TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY A. B. SIX FORTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX FORTY SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER
MCCARTY AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO ELECTIONS MR MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AT THIS MEASURE IS A
COMPANION BILL TO OUR A CA SIX
THAT FREE THE VOTE MEASURE
WHICH RESTORES VOTING RIGHTS
FOR THOSE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED. THIS IS
CONTINGENT ON THE PASSAGE OF A
CA SIX THIS WILL- REFLECT
UPDATES TO THE ELECTIONS CODE
AND CLARIFY THE PEOPLE ON PEARL
WOULD HAVE THE CHANCE TO
REGISTER REGISTER AND VOTE
MAKING OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES
AGAIN IT'S CONTINGENT ON THE
PASSAGE OF THE ACA SIX WHICH
WILL HOPEFULLY GO BEFORE THE
VOTERS THIS NOVEMBER. THANK YOU
ASKED THE RIVAL. THANK YOU
MISTER MCCARTY MISTER BONTA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX FORTY SIX
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM. SACRAMENTO FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THE BILL I
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS. THE RIGHT
AND FAIR AND SMART THING TO DO
IT'S ABOUT EXTENDING THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO VOTE. TO
OUR FELLOW CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY WITH THEIR
FAMILIES WORKING GOOD JOBS AND-
PAYING TAXES WE OFTEN TALK ON
THIS FLOOR. ABOUT THE NEED FR
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY AN
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT- WE'RE
BEHIND ON THIS WE PRIDE
OURSELVES IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
GOING FIRST BEING BEST BEEN
INNOVATORS. THERE'S NOT IN OUR
STATES WHO ALREADY PROVIDE THIS
RIGHT. TO OUR RESIDENTS- WE
SHOULD DO THE SAME ARTS AND I
VOTE ON A. B. SIX FORTY SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA DOCTOR
WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX FORTY SIX
WHICH WILL PERMIT A PERSON. WHO
WAS ON PAROLE FOR A FELONY
CONVICTION TO REGISTER TO VOTE
AND TO VOTE. THIS BILL WILL
HELP REBUILD INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED AND
REINTRODUCE THEM BACK INTO
SOCIETY. WE KNOW THAT BEING
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
POLITICAL PROCESSMAKES IT
EASIER FOR FOLKS TO GET ENGAGED
AND INVOLVED IN TO NOT. ONCE
AGAIN RE OFFEND PEOPLE HAVE THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
PARTICIPATE IN WHO THEY ELECT.
WHO THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE
AND IF YOU TRULY WANT TO RE
INTEGRATE PEOPLE BACK IN THE
COMMUNITY WE WERE BOTH AB. SIX
FORTY SIX I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK DOCTOR
WEBER SEE AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER MCCARTY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. WORK WILL OPEN THEIR
ALL ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD OF BOTH THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THOSE EYES FORTY FIVE NO
SEVENTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING BACK UP IN THE FILE TO
FILE ITEM NINE AB NINE NINETY
TWO THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE NINETY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN AND
ACTUALLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MR MULLIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
PRESENTE AB NINE NINE TWO TO
MODERNIZE THE BROWN ACTS EIGHT
AB NINE NINE TO SIMPLY
CLARIFIES THAT MEMBERS OF LOCAL
ELECTED BODIES MAY ENGAGE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA PROVIDED THEY DO
NOT INTERACT IN ANY WAY THAT
VIOLATES THE RALPH M. BROWN ACT
LANDMARK LAW FROM NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE MORE SPECIFICALLY
AB NINE NINE TWO ALLOWS MEMBERS
TO USE SOCIAL MEDIA PROVIDED
THAT A MAJORITY OF THE MEMBERS
DO NOT DISCUSS AMONG THEMSELVES
BUSINESS OF A SPECIFIC NATURE.
THAT IS WITHIN THE SUBJECT
MATTER JURISDICTION LEGISLATIVE
BODY OF THE LOCAL AGENCY AB
NINE NINE TWO DOES NOT
UNDERMINE EXISTING BRADDOCK
PROHIBITIONS BUT CLARIFIES THE
GREAT. WHO OFFICIALS AND THEIR
TEAMS ARE STRUGGLING WITH WHEN
CONNECTING WITH THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. THIS BILL DOES
NOT ENCOURAGE ALLOW LOCAL
OFFICIALS TO DELIBERATE WITHOUT
NOTICE ON SOCIAL MEDIA BUT
INSTEAD PROVIDE STRUCTURING
CLARITY TO INTERACTIONS THAT
ARE MOST LIKELY ALREADY
HAPPENING ONLINE ROUTINE-
INTERACTIONS ON SOCIAL MEDIA TO
EXCLUDE SOCIAL MEDIA
PARTICIPATION HARM CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT. AND DOES A
DISSERVICE TO THE PUBLIC WHILE
UNDERMINING TRANSPARENCY. RIGHT
NOW WE UNDERSTAND SOME CITY
ATTORNEYS ARE SUGGESTING THAT
THERE COUNCIL MEMBER STAY OFF A
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPLETELY-
BECAUSE OF THIS GRAY AREA OF
LACK OF CLARITY ON THE BROWN
ACT. MEMBERS AS MODERNIZE THE
BROWN ACT FOR THE SOCIAL MEDIA
ARAB I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN MISTER
STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE WITH. SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL AND TO
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN MATTEO
BECAUSE I KNOW THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE I I'M GONNA SPORTS
YOU TODAY BUT- THE CONCERN THAT
I HAVE AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL OF. AS I READ THE BILL.
AS WE STEP TO PREVENT TO MAKE
SURE THAT. COUNCIL MEMBERS
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OTHER
LOCAL ACTORS CAN IN FACT.
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR
CONSTITUENCIES ONLINE. THE WAY
SOME OF THE EXEMPTIONS ARE
PROVIDED IN THERE AND THE ONE
THAT WORRIES ME THE MOST IS
ABOUT THE DIGITAL ICONS. IF WE
ARE SETTING UP THE POSSIBILITY.
WHERE I COULD AS A LOCAL
ELECTED POST SOMETHING. ON THE
INTERNET ABOUT IT AND ITEM THAT
I HAVE. AND THEN RELY ON THE
LAKES FROM MY COLLEAGUES. WHICH
MY READING THE BILL CURRENTLY
SEEMS TO ALLOW. THEN THAT
SHOULD BE A VIOLATION OF THE
BROWN ACT BECAUSE NOW I HAVE
COLLECTED VOTES A LITTLE BIT
SURREPTITIOUSLY. SOCIAL MEDIA-PLATFORMS ARE NOT UBIQUITOUS
AND NOT ALL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ARE CONNECTED ON THE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS. SO IT
IS NOT AN APPROPRIATE PLACE TO
SAY WE CHECK THAT BOX BECAUSE
IT IS PUBLIC DISCOURSE IT IS
NOT PUBLIC DISCOURSE EVEN IF IT
IS A SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM THAT
IS FAIRLY COMMONLY USE. SO I
THINK WE DO NEED TO MODERNIZE
AROUND ACT WE NEED TO ACCOUNT
FOR MINOR TYPES OF
COMMUNICATIONS HOWEVER. IF WE
ARE ALLOWING EXEMPTIONS FOR
CERTAIN TYPES OF ACTIVITY WE
HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT
WHAT WE ALLOW DON'T ALLOW SO
THAT WE ARE NOT WHICH I KNOW
HE'S NOT YOUR TENSION. OPENING
DOORS FOR UNDER THE CAN'T
COUNTER COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN
MEMBERS TO BUILD CONFIDENCE IN
THE VOTE SAID THEY HAVE WITHOUT
HAVING THE PUBLIC DISCOURSE AND
BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE BY THEIR
CONSTITUENCIES SO THAT IS MY
CONCERN. THANK YOU MISTER
STONE. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER MULLIN YOU MAY CLOSE.
THEY CAME OUT OF SPEAKER I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA CRUZ- EXPRESSING HIS
CONCERNS HE BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION- IS THE LACK OF
CLARITY IN THE LANGUAGE WITH
REGARD TO ONE OF THE
EXEMPTIONS- WHEN. MULTIPLE
COUNCIL QUITE LIKE A POST BY A
COUNCIL MEMBER. ABOUT AN ISSUE
THAT IS PENDING BEFORE THE
BODY. IT IS CERTAINLY MY
ATTENTION AND I BELIEVE THEY'LL
THE LANGUAGE RIGHT NOW MAKES IT
FAIRLY CLEAR. THAT ANY. ITEM
THAT'S PENDING BEFORE THE
COUNCIL. OF THE BROWN ACT
PROVISIONS ARE APPLICABLE I
COULDN'T I AM TOTALLY COMMITTED
TO WORKING ONTHAT ISSUE WITH
REGARD TO THAT SPECIFIC
EXEMPTION. AND CLARIFYING THAT
THAT IS THAT IS NOT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO- WITH THIS BILL SO
I THANK YOU. TO THE MEMBER FROM
SANTA CRUZ RAISING THAT ISSUE I
AM FULLY COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING ADDITIONAL LOT
DEFINITIONAL- ISSUES WERE GOING
TO BE. A HOPEFULLY ON THE
SENATE SIDE OF TWEAKING THIS
LANGUAGE. LET ME JUST SAY
MEMBER SOCIAL MEDIA
INTERACTIONS AYE BROTHER BY
THEIR VERY NATURE PUBLIC. AND
THE BROWN ACT MUCH OF THE
INTENT BEHIND THE ORIGINAL
BROWN ACT WAS TO MAKE SURE
DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE
OUTSIDE OF PUBLIC VIEW SOCIAL
MEDIA BY ITS VERY NATURE. ARE
PUBLIC AND TRANSPARENT-
INTERACTIONS OUGHT COUNCIL
MEMBERS HAVE COME TO MY OFFICE
AND OTHER LOCAL FFICIALS
ASKING FOR ACTION AND CLARITY.
I IN THIS REGARD THAT'S WERE
TENDING TO DO WITH THIS BILL
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
BOOK. THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED
THE. ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE WELL LOU. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE
EYES FORTY EIGHT KNOWS THIRTEEN
THIS MEASURE PASSES. IN A FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE A. B. SIXTEEN
OH EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH EIGHT
BY FAMILY MEMBER HOLDEN AND
ACTUALLY THE COMMUNITY CARE
FACILITIES MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IN MEMBERS- AB SIXTEEN
OH EIGHT. WILL GIVE US THE
TOOLS TO EVALUATE THE LICENSING
AND CRIMINAL EXEMPTION PROCESS.
THE BILL CALLS ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TO BEGIN COLLECTING DATA FROM
CLEARANCE AN EXEMPTION
APPLICATIONS SPECIFICALLY
DEMOGRAPHICS ON AGE ETHNICITY
GENDER AND CONVICTED CRIMES
FROM APPLICATIONS THAT ARE
DENIED. CLEARANCE AND
EXEMPTIONS. CURRENTLY THIS
INFORMATION IS NOT COLLECTED
FROM APPLICATIONS THAT ARE
DENIED OR GRANTED CLEARANCE OR
EXEMPTIONS WHICH IS A GREAT
DISSERVICE TO THE FACILITIES
AND LEGAL SERVICES AND CENTERS
THAT FIGHT EVERY DAY. THESE
APPLICANTS RIGHT TO WORK. THIS
DOWN IT WILL SHOW THE
CONSISTENT OPERATE REPRESSION
OF JULY'S COMMUNITIES WHICH
WILL HIGHLIGHT AND DEMAND FOR
GREATER CHAIN. AND CURRENT
SYSTEM. WHEN WE GET EVERYONE I
AT THE TABLE TO THE TO. WITH
THIS. WE WILL BE ABLE TO REAL
CHANGE TOGETHER. THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES FROM REQUIRING
A PERSON TO DESCRIBE THEIR OWN
CONVICTIONS ON THE INITIAL
APPLICATION AND THEREFORE
CREATING A CANDOR TROUT. DSS
MUST RELY O THE MORE ACCURATE
DOJ F. B. I. RECORDS TO BODY
WEIGHT AN APPLICANT. THESE ARE
THE SAME RECORDS THAT I ITS S.
S. AIRPORTS IN MANY OTHER STATE
AND FEDERAL AGENTS LEASE RELY
ON. I HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE CHILD CARE ADVOCATES. DSS
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS OVER THE
RECESS AND AMENDMENTS MADE IN
APPROPRIATIONS ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS. THE AMENDMENTS
REMOVED CHANGES TO THE
EXEMPTION PROCESS THAT
ADVOCATES RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE LIMITS IT TO THE CANDOR
TRAP. AND DATA COLLECTION
SECTIONS I DESCRIBED WHICH IS
WHY THE CHILD CARE AND SENIOR
HOME ADVOCATES ARE NEUTRAL AND
THEREFORE THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
HOLDEN. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. RIGHT. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESERT ABOUT.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE%
IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY
FOUR NEWS FIFTEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY TWO A. B. SIXTEEN
SEVENTY TWO THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SEVENTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE SOLID
WASTE MR BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO
SEEKS TO PROVIDE CLEAR CONSUMER
INFORMATION ABOUT. HOW
CONSUMERS SHOULD PROPERLY
DISPOSE OF SINGLE USE WET WHITE
PRODUCTS WITH THE INTENT OF
KEEPING NON DISPERSIBLE WIPES
OUT OF OUR SEWER SYSTEMS. IN
THE LAST FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
YEARS THERE BEEN A PLAYER
PROLIFERATION OF SINGLE USE
WENT WHITE PRODUCTS THAT HAVE
COME INTO THE RETAIL MARKET
AND- MANY OF THESE PRODUCTS ARE
INTENDED TO BE DISPOSED OF IN
THE TRASH CAN. NOT DOWN THE
TOILET. HOWEVER THERE'S A
GROWING SUITE OF THESE PRODUCTS
THAT ARE MARKETS FLUSHABLE FOR
SEWER AND SEPTIC SAFE. AND SOME
OF THEM ARE NOT WHEN WET WHITE
PRODUCTS ARE FLUSHED INTO THE
SEWER SYSTEM. THEY CAN CAUSE
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES FOR PRIVATE
PROPERTY OWNERS SEWER
COLLECTIONS AND WASTE WATER
TREATMENT PLANTS. SINGLE USE
WET WIPES ARE HEAVIER THICKER
AND HAVE LARGER SURFACE AREAS
THAN TOILET PAPER AND RESEARCH
SHOWSTHAT WIPES MAINTAIN MOST
OF THEIR STRENGTH BECAUSE THERE
COMPOSED OF SYNTHETIC MATERIALS
OR PLASTIC THAT RETAINS SHAPE
AND STRENGTH. WIPES DOWN OFTEN
DO NOT BREAK DOWN AFTER BEING
FLUSHED AND THEY CAN ACCUMULATE
WITH FATS OR OILS AND GREASE
AND BECOME LARGE OBSTRUCTIONS
IN THE PIPES. FURTHER DOWN THE
LINE THEY WEAVE TOGETHER AND
CREATE GIANT THAT WATER
ESSENTIALLY GIANT RAGS WHICH
CAN GET SECOND PUMPS COLLECTION
SYSTEMS AND MOTORS CAUSING
BACKUPS AND EQUIPMENT FAILURES.
THIS PROBLEM IS EXPERIENCE
ACROSS THE STATE THE COUNTRY
AND WORLDWIDE AS DISPOSABLE
WHAT WHAT PRODUCTS ÐOME MORE
AND MORE WIDELY AVAILABLE. SO
THIS BILL PROVIDES A PRESCRIBES
CLEAR AND CONSISTENT CONSUMER
MESSAGING FOR THESE PRODUCTS
THAT INDICATES THE CONSUMER
THAT EITHER A WIFE IS FLUSHABLE
OR IT'S NOT. PUBLICATION SEASON
WHITE MANUFACTURERS HAVE AGREED
TO CONTINUE NEGOTIATIONS AS
THIS BILL MOVES TO THE SENATE
ASSUMING. YOU'RE ALL AGREEABLE
AND WE AGREE THAT THE IMPROPER
DISPOSABLE THAT EVERYONE AGREES
THAT THE IMPROPER DISPOSAL. OF
WET WIPES IN MUNICIPAL SEWER
SYSTEMS IS CAUSING MAJOR
PROBLEMS FOR PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THAT CURRENT
LABELING IS QUITE INADEQUATE.
WE WILL FURTHER OUR DISCUSSIONS
ON A HOST OF ISSUES INCLUDING A
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
ADDITIONAL STUDIES AND RESEARCH
AND JUST AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS FLUSTERED FLEXIBILITY
STANDARDS. AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
TWO IS SUPPORTED BY OVER SIXTY
PUBLIC AGENCIES UNIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATION NGOS
STATEWIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WATER ASSOCIATION AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION HERE TODAY I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE SO WE MAY
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS BILL.
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. WORK WILL CREWS LOW'S THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE EYE
FORTY NINE NO SIXTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES. IN A FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE AB TWO NINETY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TO NINETY ONE BY SIMPLY
MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND ACTUALLY
TO EMERGENCY SERVICES MISTER
KANSEN CHU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
HUMAN THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
SAM MEMBERS I RISE 2% AB TWO
NINETY ONE WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH A FUNDING STRUCTURE
TO ENSURE ALL CITIES AND
COUNTIES ALL PREPARE FOR ANY
DISASTER THAT MIGHT COME THEIR
WAY. IN THE PAST COUPLE YEARS
TO HAVE BEEN TWELFTH
PRESIDENTIAL AJOR DISASTER.
DECLARATION IN CALIFORNIA I
DON'T HAVE TO REMIND YOU THAT
I'LL HAVE BEEN DEVASTATING
FIRES- MUST LIFE THAN FLOOD
THERE HAVE RESULT IN LIFE LOSS
AND CALLS MAJOR DAMAGES MANY
COMMITTEE IN CALIFORNIA A STILL
WORKING TO PICK UP THE PIECES
AND REBUILD. ACCORDING TO A
STUDY BY THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE
OF BUILDING SCIENCE EVERY ONE
DOLLAR WE SPEND ON MITIGATION
THEM PREPAREDNESS WE CAN SAVE
THE NATION'S SIX DOLLARS AND
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECT. ASK RIVALED. THE YOU
MISTER CHOOSE AND HEARING NO
FURTHER TO ON THE MATTER THE
CLERK OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE HELLO. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WILL FLOWS THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO FILE ITEM NINETEEN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NINETEEN BY
MISTER MURATSUCHI A. B. THREE
TO SIX CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
ACTUALLY THE MOTORIZED ARING
DEVICES MISSION MURATSUCHI
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS AB
THREE TO SIX. IS A SIMPLE BILL
THAT'S A RECEIVED A UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. THIS
IS A SIMPLE BILL THAT WOULD
ALLOW PERSONALLY OWN MOTORIZED
CARING DEVICES- TO BE USED ON
CITY SIDEWALKS AS STRONG
SUPPORT FROM TECHNET. AND
OTHERS IN THE TECH INDUSTRY.
JUST IMAGINE LIKE A LITTLE R.
TWO D. TWO CARING YOU ALL YOUR
STUFF YOUR GROCERIES ON A CITY
SIDEWALK IT'S GOING TO I WAS
TRYING TO GET A MODEL ON THE
FLOOR BUT I. WAS CONCERNED THAT
I MIGHT BE ADVERTISING. ACCUSED
OF ADVERTISING PRODUCTS BUT
IT'S A GOOD BILL HIGH ASK FOR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
PURSUE G. SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. I PREFER B. B. EIGHT
WAY CAR CALL THE ROLL. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SITE ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
BUT I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WHERE ONE MOVED TO
TAKE A FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE.
AB ELEVEN NINETY SIX BY MISTER
GIBSON CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BALL OF A NINETY SIX
BY SOME REMEMBER GIPSON AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. MISTER
GIBSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ARE
RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN NINETY SIX WHICH WOULD
ECSTATICALLY STATEWIDE MODEL
AND GRANT PROGRAM THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS COMMUNITY SCHOOLS ARE
ABOUT RE IMAGINING OF EDUCATION
IN CALIFORNIA. COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS OR MODELS ALREADY EXIST
ON THE LOCAL LEVEL THESE
SCHOOLS INTEGRATE THE MENTAL
AND PHYSICAL HEALTH SERVICES.
IS THE OUTSIDE OR FOR STUDENTS
WHO HAVE NEEDS MANY OF THE
STUDENTS COME FROM UNSTABLE
HOMES EXPERIENCED TRAUMA AND
LACK OF RESOURCES. THESE
PRESSURES OUTSIDE THE CLASSROOM
HINDER STUDENTS FROM FORMING
INSIDE THE CLASSROOM COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS EFFECTIVELY ADDRESSES
EXTERNAL PRESSURES THROUGH
WRAPAROUND SERVICES INCREASE
PARENTS ENGAGEMENT ASEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN NINETY SIX WILL
HELP CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
FOR OUR STUDENTS ELEVEN NINETY
THIS IS ABOUT ACT HE- AND IS
ABOUT MAKING SURE THE KIDS GET
THE KIND OF SERVICES THEY NEED
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
ON IT NINETY SIX. THANK YOU MS
GIBSON SAY NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CLICK LIBERAL ALL
MEMBERS. ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY ONE. KNOWS
ELEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
SENATE THIRD READING FILE ITEMS
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT PASS
RETAIN. THERE WAS REMOVED THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. DOES ANY
MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN ITEM FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SING
HEARING ON THE CLERK WILL READ
THE SICKENING IS A CALENDAR A
SOME RESOLUTION ONE. A MEMBER
LOW RELATIVE TO PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGIST WEEK. PARK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG CONSENT ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF VOTE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL.
TELL YOU ABOUT AYE SIXTY NINE
KNOWS YOU'RE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. CLICK READ
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HOUSE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY ONE I SIXTY
NINE OH ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL A
TWENTY THREE I SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO ASSIGNABLE NINE TEN I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SOME LEGAL
NINE FIFTY THREE I SIXTY NINE
OH ZERO SOME PEOPLE CALL THE
FIVE. I SIXTY NINE OH ZERO IT'S
ONLY WILL TOLD SIXTY THREE I
SIX NINE TWO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
FOURTEEN SIXTY NINE I SIXTY
NINE ZERO AND ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN TWELVE. SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO. ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST NO FLOOR
SESSION- CHECK IN SESSION.
MONDAY FEBRUARY THIRD THE FLOOR
SESSION IS AT ONE PM. MEMBERS
WE ARE AT ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
THANK
YOU MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
WERE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION
TO SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MISS PETRIE-NORRIS. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF NINE
CALIFORNIANS WHO DIED IN A
TRAGIC HELICOPTER ACCIDENT LAST
SUNDAY JANUARY TWENTY SIX
TWENTY TWENTY. TODAY WE
REMEMBER KOBE AND JOHNNY
BRYANT. JOHN KERRY ANALYST'S
ALTOBELLI SERRA AND PEYTON
CHESTER CRISTINA MOSSER AND ARE
AS THE BAYAN. THE GROUP WAS
FINE FROM ORANGE COUNTY TO
THOUSAND OAKS FOR A BASKETBALL
GAME KOBE BRYANT WAS SET TO
COACH HIS DAUGHTER CHIANA AND
HER TWO TEAMMATES. AS WE WELL
KNOW KOBE BRYANT IS A LEGEND.
TWENTY SEASONS WITH THE LOS
ANGELES LAKERS FIVE NBA TITLES
TWO OLYMPIC GOLD MEDALS. THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE CAREER POINTS. BUT
TODAY WE ARE NOT JUST GRIEVING
FOR A LEGEND. WE ARE GRIEVING
AS IF WE KNEW HIM AND IN A WAY
WE DID. WE KNEW HIS HOPES WE
SHARED HIS HEART BREAK. WE KNEW
THE FEROCITY OF HIS FIGHTS.
WITHOUT HIS TRIUMPH AND HIS
JUBILATION AND SO TODAY WE FEEL
HIS ABSENCE WE MOURN HIS LOSS
DEEPLY. AND PERSONALLY AND
TODAY OUR HEARTS BREAK FOR HIS
WIFE VANESSA IN FOR THEIR THREE
SURVIVING DAUGHTERS KOBE'S
DAUGHTER. JOHNNY BRYANT GIGI
WAS POISED TO FOLLOW IN HER
FATHER'S FOOTSTEPS THE
BASKETBALL STAR IN THE MAKING
SHE WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR HER
BIG SMILE. HER BIG HEART
INTERFERE SUPPLY. JOHN IS
BRENDAN TEAMMATES ALYSSA
ALTOBELLI WAS ON THIS FLIGHT
WITH HER PARENTS JOHN AND CARRY.
JOHN ALTOBELLI WITH THE MATCH
LEFT BASKETBALL BASEBALL COACH
AT ORANGE COAST COLLEGE IN
COSTA MESA COACH ALTER WAS
ENTERING HIS TWENTY EIGHTH
SEASON LEADING THE PIRATES HE
WAS A TREMENDOUS COACH AN
AMAZING MENTOR BUT ON AND OFF
THE FIELD. JOHN AND HIS WIFE
KERRY MADE EVERYONE FEEL LIKE
FAMILY. AND I AM DEVASTATED FOR
THEIR TWO SURVIVING CHILDREN.
AND WISH THEM A PEACE THAT
PASSES ALL UNDERSTANDING.
MUMBAI ACADEMY TEAMMATE PEYTON
CHESTER AND HER MOTHER SARAH
CHESTER. RESIDENTS OF SAN JUAN
CAPISTRANO. AND CONSTITUENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER PRO. FAMILY
DESCRIBED PEYTON AS THE
GENTLEST PERSON YOU WOULD EVER
MEET AND HER MOM SARAH IS THE
ONE THAT EVERYBODY COUNTED ON.
CRISTINA MOSSER HUNTINGTON
BEACH BASKETBALL COACH TEACHER
AND MOTHER OF THREE WAS THE MOM
MAMBAS TOP DEFENSIVE COACH.
KOBE HIMSELF CALLED HER THE
MOTHER OF DEFENSE. THE
HELICOPTER'S PILOT ARE THE
BAYAN HAD A PASSION FOR FLYING
AND IT'S BEEN TWENTY YEARS FINE
AND INSTRUCTING IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE LOST
NEIGHBORS MOTHERS FATHER'S
CHILDREN AND FRIENDS NOT ALL OF
THESE PASSENGERS HAD FAN CLUBS
NOT ALL OF THEM WERE HOUSEHOLD
NAMES. BUT EVERYONE OF THEM WAS
LEFT AND DEEPLY AND EVERYONE OF
THEM IS MESSED PROFOUNDLY. FOR
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE MISSING
THEM EVERYONE OF THEM. WITH A
SUPERSTAR HERO AND ELECTIONS.
IS KOBE BRYANT HIMSELF SAID THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING IS TO TRY
AND INSPIRE PEOPLE SO THAT THEY
CAN BE GREAT AT WHATEVER THEY
WANT TO ACCOMPLISH. THE WE
REMEMBER THEM MAY THEIR MEMORY
BE AN INSPIRATION AND A
BLESSING. THANK YOU IS
PETRIE-NORRIS DOCTOR WEBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. MISTER SPEAKER
IN MEMBERS I'D TO RISE SO ON OF
IN MEMORY OF KOBE BRYANT AND
THOSE WHO WERE LOST WITH HIM
THIS PAST SUNDAY. AS CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS I STAND TODAY
PARTICULARLY IN MEMORY OF KOBE
BRYANT. NOT FOR THE FIVE TIME
WORLD CHAMPION WITH THE LAKERS
OR THE TWO TIME OLYMPIC
MEDALIST. AND THE OSCAR WINNER
MOST RECENTLY. BUT FOR THE IN
HIM BEING A DEDICATED FATHER A
HUSBAND A LOT PHILANTHROPIST
AND A STRONG MENTOR IN THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY. I'M
SURE ALL OF YOUR WHERE HIS
COURT SUCCESS IN NOTHING STANDS
OUT MORE HOWEVER THEN HIS
MENTALITY FOR SUCCESS. HIS
TRADEMARK WAS THE MONUMENTALITY
WHICH COULD BE APPLIED TO
EVERYONE'S LIFE. IN THIS
MENTALITY IS DESCRIBED IN HIS
OWN WORDS WHEN HE SAYS THE
MINDSET IS AN ABOUT SEEKING A
RESULT. IT'S MORE ABOUT THE
PROCESS OF GETTING TO THAT
RESULT. IT'S ABOUT THE JOURNEY
AND THE APPROACH IT'S A LIFE.
WE TALKED KOBE BRYANT BEGIN OF.
IS PEIRCE VENTURES WITH AND
FAMILY HE CO FOUNDED THE KOBE
AND VANESSA BRYANT FAMILY
FOUNDATION THE OFFICIAL AND HE
WAS THE OFFICIAL AMBASSADOR FOR
THE AFTER SCHOOL ALL STARS A
CHAMPION FOR STAND UP TO CANCER
PROVIDING MOTIVATIONAL MESSAGES
TO THOSE BATTLING CANCER AND I
HAS DONATED MORE THAN A MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE NATIONAL MUSEUM
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN HISTORY AND
CULTURE IN WASHINGTON DC. AS
POINTED OUT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT HE WAS THE FOR HE HE WAS
THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN TO
WIN AN ACADEMY AWARD FOR BEST.
ANIMATED SHORT FILM WHEN HE
WROTE IN THEIR RATED DEAR
BASKETBALL. HIS FAVORITE PART
OF RETIRING WAS SPENDING TIME
WITH HIS FAMILY AND BEING A
MENTOR SHARING HIS KNOWLEDGE
WITH OTHERS ABOUT THE GAME HE
LOVED. THIS YOUNG MAN WAS
MAKING SURE THAT HIS POST
CAREER FOOTPRINT WAS JUST AS
IMPACTFUL AS A FOOTPRINT HE
LEFT ON THE COURT. YOU KNOW
IT'S INTERESTING WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT. KOBE BRYANT AND HIS
IMPACT UPON OTHER PEOPLE'S
LIVES. AND TALKING WITH A YOUNG
MAN HE SAID THERE WERE THREE
THINGS HE WANTED TO DO IN LIFE.
HE WANTED TO MEET OBAMA. HONOR
TO MEET JZ. AND HE WANTED TO BE
KOBE. THOSE ARE THE THREE THAT
HE FELT WERE IMPACTFUL IN HIS
LIFE AND I FOUND THAT TO BE
QUITE INTERESTING. WHEN I SEE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IT HAPPENS
IN DEATH IS JUST A PART OF
LIFE. AND ANY OF US WHO THINK
IT'S NOT WE'LL FIND OUT FAIRLY
SOON. THAT I ALWAYS THINK ABOUT
WHAT IS IN ME WHAT CAN WE LEARN
FROM THIS BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY
WHERE IT'S ALL ABOUT. WE CAN
MOURN. WE CAN PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR FAMILIES WE CAN DO THOSE
THINGS THAT THE HELP EASE THE
PAIN BUT THE PAIN WILL BE THERE
IF YOU'VE EVER LOST. A LOVED
ONE IT WILL BE THERE AT ONLY
TIME AND WORKING THROUGH IT
WILL BASICALLY HELP YOU. WITH A
LOT OF THINGS THAT WE LEARN IN
THE PROCESS WHEN WE WHEN WE'RE
CONFRONTED WITH DEATH. I'M
REMINDED OFTENTIMES ABOUT
METHUSELAH. THE BIBLE TELLS AS
WITH LOSE A LIVE NINE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY NINE YEARS. AND THEN
DIED. THAT'S ALL WE HAVE IS A
RECORD OF HIM. NO ACTIVITY. NO
CONTRIBUTIONS. WE KNOW WHOSE
FATHER WAS WHOSE CHILDREN WERE.
BUT HE LIVE NINE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE YEARS ACCORDING TO
THE SCRIPTURE. AND THEN DIED.
AND I THINK ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
THERE ARE SO MANY OF US WHO.
WHO WILL ONLY LIVE THIRTY FORTY
YEARS. AND YET THAT'S PERIOD IN
BETWEEN BIRTH AND DEATH. IS
FIELD. FEEL WITH THINGS THAT
WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED. FEEL WHAT
HOW WE MAKE PEOPLE FEEL. FILLED
AT THINGS OF WHAT THEY DID IN
OUR LIFE AND HOW WE SAW THEM
AND THE IMPACT OF THEIR LIFE.
WILL LIVE FOR EVER AND EVER
BECAUSE IF NOT WHAT THEY DID
BUT HOW THEY MADE YOU FEEL AS A
HUMAN BEING. AND HOW THEY HELP
YOU TO ACCOMPLISH YOUR GOALS.
WHEN I THINK ABOUT SOMEBODY
SAYS. CALL WAS LIFE ISTOO
SHORT IT WAS UNTIMELY. AND
ALWAYS. THE THING HOLES OF.
WE'RE NOT CHARGE OF THE CLOCK
SOME ELSE'S INTO OF THE CLOCK
SO WE CALL IT UNTIMELY IT'S
MAYBE OUR TIME BUT IT'S NOT THE
REAL TIME BECAUSE ALL OF US DIE
AT OUR TIME. AND SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT WHILE WE GRIEVE ABOUT IT
WE HAVE SO MUCH TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO FIGHT FOR
OUR DREAMS AS HE FOUGHT FOR
HIS. WE DOING TO HELP OTHERS
ACCOMPLISH DEIRDRE HE DID HOW
WILL WE MAKE OUR LEGACY AN
IMPORTANT LEGACY A LEGACY
THAT'S ONLY FORTY ONE YEARS
LONG AND YET MORE IMPACTFUL
THAN SOMEONE WHO LIVED NINE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE YEARS. I
WANT TO FEEL OF THE OTHER DAY
OF A GENTLEMAN WHO WAS NINETY
FOUR YEARS OLD. AND PEOPLE
THEIR GRIEVED AS IF HE WERE
FOURTEEN. BECAUSE HE STILL
WORKED EVERY DAY TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND HE HAD PROJECTS
HE WAS WORKING ON ANY HAD
THINGS HE WAS GIVING PEOPLE AND
HE WAS SHARING HIS HISTORY OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN SAN DIEGO.
AND SO WE GRIEVE FOR HIM AS IF
HE WERE JUST A KID GETTING
READY TO DO SOMETHING ELSE
BECAUSE I ALWAYS WAS READY AND
GETTING READY TO DO SOMETHING
ELSE. WE GRIEVE FOR HIM AND HIS
FAMILY BECAUSE WE KNOW NOT SO
MUCH FOR HIM BUT HIS FAMILY.
THE THING MESSED. HE WILL DANCE
DOOR WEDDING. YOU WON'T WALKING
DOWN I. THESE ARE THINGS THAT
MANY OF US HAVE X. IN OUR LIFE
NOT BECAUSE THEY WERE FAMOUS
BUT BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT BRING US JOY BUT AT
PURPOSE TO I'LL HAVE AND GIVE
US A FOCUS IN LOOKING AT WHAT
WE NEED TO DO. RIGHT I THINK OF
THE FACT THAT. THE THING I
WOULD MISS IS THE SECOND
CHAPTER OF HIS LIFE. WE ALSO
THE FIRST CHAPTER THE SPORTS.
AND WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
SECOND CHAPTER WOULD LOOK LIKE
AND YET HE GAVE US SOME
EXAMPLES IN MANY WAYS OF HOW
HARD HE WOULD WORK TO
ACCOMPLISH HIS STRINGS. AND A
HEART HE WILL WORK TO MAKE
THINGS RIGHT. BUT HE ALSO GAVE
US ANOTHER EXAMPLE MOST PEOPLE.
THE MORNING BEFORE YOU GOT ON
THE PLANE. AFTER HE WENT TO
CHURCH AND HE PRAYED. AND I
THOUGHT TO MYSELF HE KNEW WHO
WAS IN CONTROL OF THE UNIVERSE
NOT KOBE BRYANT NOT THE
HELICOPTER DRIVER BUT THE
PERSON HE PRAYED TO. AND IT WAS
HIS TIME IN MAY NOT OF BEEN
HOURS BUT WAS HE IS AND THE
MOST WE CAN TAKE FROM IT IS
THAT ALL OF US USE EVERY MOMENT
OF THE DAY TO THOSE THINGS WE
KNOW ALL RIGHT TO NEVER DID
LATE THE STATEMENT THAT I LOVE
YOU. NEVER PLAY THE IMPORTANCE
OF FOLKS IN YOUR LIFE NEVER
FORGET TO SAY THANK YOU. NEVER
FORGET TO DO THOSE THINGS THAT
THANK YOU WOULD DO IN THE
FUTURE BUT YOU GO TO THEIR PRO
TIME THIS IS THE TOP. THE TIME.
IS TO. I ACTUALLY ASSET WITH A
J. MEMBER OF KOBE. AND WE GIVE
LAW AND TO FAMILY AND TO THOSE
WHO WERE WITH HIM AT THAT TIME
BECAUSE I'M SURE TE LIFE WAS
FULL. COMPLEX MANY THINGS AND
IT WAS THEIR TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER IS
KAMLAGER. YOUR RECOGNIZE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I TO RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF THE
NINE VICTIMS THAT PERISHED IN
THE FIRE AND TO SPEAK TO A LIFE
OF KOBE BRYANT. AN ICON IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND BEYOND.
MANY OF HIS PHILANTHROPIC
ACTIVITIES AND COMMUNITY VISITS
LANDED HIM IN THE FIFTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AS WELL AS
MANY DISTRICTS ACROSS THE SOUTH
WIND. KOBE BRYANT PERSONIFIED
PASSION PRIDE AND PERSEVERANCE.
EVEN WITH HIS GOD GIVEN
EXTRAORDINARY TALENT HE OUT
WORKED EVERY OPPONENT HE FACED.
HAVING MASTERED THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF HIGH STAKES
COMPETITIVE SPORT HE
TRANSCENDED EVEN THAT. AND
BUILT A TWO BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT PORTFOLIO. HE
CHAMPIONED GIRLS ATHLETICS AND
PREDICTED THAT THE DAY WILL
SOON BE WHEN A WOMAN PLAYS IN
THE NBA. HE NEVER FALTERED
CARRYING THE INSATIABLE DEMANDS
OF A PRIVILEGED METROPOLIS.
EVEN WHEN THE CITY BLANCHED AT
HIM. HE EMBODIED AT ONCE
EXTREME GREATNESS AND PROFOUND
NORMALCY. RIPPLE SORRY IN PART
J. REST IN PEACE BLACK MAMBA.
THERE WAS KAMLAGER. SHE APRIL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I TO RISE TODAY
TO REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF KOBE BRYANT AND OF
THE OTHER EIGHT VICTIMS OF THE
TRAGIC HELICOPTER CRASH ON
SUNDAY AND ONE- ECHO THE VERY
ELOQUENT COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THIS TRAGIC LOSS
WAS FELT VERY DEEPLY IN MY
COMMUNITY. FOR MANY REASONS NOT
THE LEAST OF WHICH WAS THAT THE
HELICOPTER CRASH OCCURRED IN
CALABASAS IN MY DISTRICT. I IN
THE HILLS JUST ACROSS FROM A
RIGHT MIDDLE SCHOOL AND THE LAS
VIRGENES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. IN FOR SO MANY IN THE
WEST SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AS
ACROSS LOS ANGELES KOBE. BRYANT
WAS SO MUCH MORE THAN
BASKETBALL HE WAS THE LAKERS HE
WAS THE NBA. AND HE WAS THE
CHILDHOOD HERO FOR MANY IN OUR
DISTRICT. IS ALSO A OP. LOSS
FOR OUR STAFF- MY DISTRICT
DIRECTOR KATHRYN CODDINGTON WHO
IS VERY ABLY SERVED OUR
COMMUNITY. SINCE I. TOOK
OFFICE- WORKED FOR KOBE BRYANT
FOR ALMOST FOUR YEARS. ON AN
ALMOST DAILY BASIS SHE WAS
INVOLVED IN HIS MEDIA RELATIONS
A NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS. AND
SO THIS WAS A VERY PERSONAL
LOSS FOR OUR EIGHTY FORTY FIVE
FAMILY. AND WAS SPEAKING WITH
HER LAST NIGHT OF REFLECTING ON
HER EXPERIENCE AS IN THE-
REALLY UP CLOSE AND UNVARNISHED
VIEW THAT SHE GOT OF KOBE OVER
THE TIME THAT SHE- WORKED WITH
HIM. AND SHE HAD A NUMBER OF
REFLECTIONS THAT AND THOUGHT
WERE WORTH WHAT WAS JUST THE
VIEW THAT SHE OF HIS TIRELESS
WORK ETHIC IN HIS RELENTLESS
DRIVE TO BE VAST EVERYTHING HE
DID. FROM THE FOR OUR THIRD.
PRE WORKOUT THAT HE COULD DO
OUT LEAVING A LATE THE GAME. TO
THE FACT THAT WE MISSED SHOT
THE STAFF FOR THE GAME AND TAKE
THAT SHOT OFF INTO FOR AN HOUR.
FROM EXACT SAME SPOT. A IS. DID
ON INCREDIBLE FOR THE GAME OF
SHE SAID HAD NO DOUBT IN HER
THAT IF YOU DIDN'T MAKE A IF
YOU'VE NEVER BEEN PAID HE
WOULD'VE WORK JUST AS HARD TO
PERFECT HIS GAME BECAUSE THAT
WAS WHO HE WAS AND THAT WAS
WHAT HE WAS ABOUT AND SHE ALSO
REFLECTED ON HIS VERY VERY
SINCERE AND GENUINE COMMITMENT
TO PHILANTHROPY I SOME OF YOU
MAY KNOW HE WAS ONE OF THE TOP
WHICH GRANTORS FOR THE MAKE A
WISH STATION. TO HUNDRED
FAMILIES DATING SO WHERE HE
CAME INTO A RASH AND ALMOST
ALMOST ALL THE WITHOUT. OUT NO.
NOBODY KNEW. THIS WOULD BE-TAKING TIME AWAY FROM SCHEDULE
WHERE EVERY MINUTE OF HIS LIFE
WAS SCHEDULED TO GO IN SAID.
OFTEN FOR LENGTHY PERIODS OF
TIMES WITH CHILDREN WITH
FAMILIES THAT WERE STRUGGLING
THROUGH DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES. NOT BECAUSE
ANYBODY WOULD FIND OUT ABOUT IT
NOT BECAUSE IT WOULD GET HIM
GOOD PUBLICITY. BECAUSE HE FELT
THAT THAT WAS THE RIGHT THING.
HELLO SO I THINK THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT WE THINK
ABOUT WHEN REMEMBER KOBE BRYANT.
AND FOR ME ONE OF THE MEASURES
OF HIS IMPACT IS HOW. AM IS HOW
DEEPLY HIS LOSS WAS FELT BY SO
MANY IN OUR IN OUR COMMUNITY
REGARDLESS OF. AGE OR
BACKGROUND OR INTEREST IN THE
GAME OF BASKETBALL OR WHETHER
YOU KNEW HIM OR NOT. THERE WAS
JUST THIS PROFOUND REALLY
SHARED SENSE OF LOSS. AMONG
PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY AND
ACROSS. LOS ANGELES IN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
WORLD AND SO. AS WE REMEMBER
THOSE VICTIMS REMEMBER KOBE
BRYANT SOMEBODY WHO TRANSCENDS
THE GAME. HE WILL BE DEEPLY
MASTIN I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY- AND ALSO THE MEMORY OF
JOHN A BRYANT. OF JOHN KERRY
AND I'LL SO ALL FELLOW. OF
COURSE. MOST SARAH AND PAIN
CHEST. AND OUR HOURS OF. THANK
YOU. NAME IS K. MISTER GIBSON.
YOU ARE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AYE
CERTAINLY- CONCUR WITH AL THAT
HAVE BEEN SAID AS OF REFLECTION
OF THOSE WHO- LIFE WAS LOSS IN
THE TRAGIC ACCIDENT- ON SUNDAY-
MANY OF US REMEMBER WHERE WE
WERE DURING JOHN F. KENNEDY.
ASSASSINATION MAR THE KING. I
CAN'T REMEMBER I WAS IN CHURCH
AND SO I WAS IN CHURCH AND ONE
OF MY TEAM MEMBERS TOUCH
MINNESOTA SAID- MR GIVES THAT I
HAVE SOME BAD NEWS AND HE SAID
THAT KOBE BRYANT DIED I SAID.
NO CHECK YOUR FAX WE WANT TO BE
CLEAR. AND THEN THE NEW START
COMING IN. MEMBERS I CAN GET ON
THIS FLOOR AND- TELL YOU THAT.
I MET THIS GREAT MAN. THAT IS
UNTRUE I'VE NEVER MET KOBE
BRYANT I'M FROM LOS ANGELES
WARNER REYES BUT THE LOSS OF
THIS MAN AND ALL THAT WAS ON
THAT HELICOPTER IT FELT LIKE I
MY FAMILY. SO EVERY DAY SINCE
THE SITUATION OF TAKEN PLACE
WHICH CHECKING THE FEE WHICH
CHECKING TO SEE WAS ON FACEBOOK
AND SOCIAL MEDIA TO GIVE ME A
GLANCEOF EXTENDED FAMILY
MEMBER WHO I CAN NEVER SEE
AGAIN WE KNOW THAT HE WAS A
GREAT BASKETBALL ATHLETES WE
KNOW THAT HE WAS A
PHILANTHROPIST. BUT I WANT TO
TALK JUST BRIEFLY ABOUT THE
FATHER. ABOUT THE MAN WHO HAD
FOUR BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTERS. BI
RACIAL DAUGHTERS. THE NASA
BEING LED LATINO THE SENSE AND
KOBE BRYANT BEING OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS THAT BEAUTIFUL FAMILY.
PITCH REST FAMILY. HOW HE I
THINK THAT YES HE LOVE
BASKETBALL BUT GUESS WHAT I
BELIEVE HE LOVE BEING A DADDY
MORE THAN EVER AND AS A MATTER
OF FACT IT IS THIS EVEN TALKED
ABOUT HERE LET US REMEMBER THE
HASH TAG HASHTAG GIRL DANCE.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I THINK
THAT HE ENJOYED THE MOST OF
BEING A FATHER. A BEING A DAD
YES ABOUT THE THAT THE BEING A
GREAT BASKETBALL PLAYER IN AND
ALL THE THINGS THAT GOES ALONG
WITH IT BUT I THINK MOST OF ALL
HE- ALSO TALKED ABOUT AN
pTWENTY MOMENTS TWENTY MINUTES.
HE WANTED TO SPEND THAT TWENTY
MINUTES WITH HIS GIRLS. IT'S
HARD RANGING FROM ME. I AM SURE
OTHERS AND YOU'RE NOT HIS
AMERICA WHO LOST HIS GREAT MAN.
AND DOCTOR WEBER TALKED ABOUT
TIME THE BIBLE ECCLESIASTIC
TALKS ABOUT THERE'S A TIME TO
LIVE THERE'S A TIME TO DIE. AND
I WAS SIMPLY SAY THE IT WAS
JUST HIS TIME. AND WE SHOULD
EMBRACE AS MEMORY CONTINUE ON
HIS LEGACY. AND AS I AS I
CLOSE. I JUST SIMPLY WANT TO
SAY THAT WE SHOULD NEVER FORGET
NOTING ABOUT KOBE BRYANT G. E.
KOBE'S FAMILY THOSE WHO LOVE
HIM. BUT ALSO THE OTHER
PASSENGERS ON THE WHOLE THERE'S
pFORGET. I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
ARE IN THE MEMORY KNOW IF KOBE.
BUT THOSE WHO WENT ON A
TRANSITION WITH A. THERE WAS
GIPSON MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU- AND
I TO- RISING TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF THE PASSENGERS REALLY
THE FAMILIES BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THEY REPRESENT WELL
IT'S THE OUT THE BELLY
ALTOBELLI FAMILY CHESTER TO
BRIAN MAUSER AND EVEN THE PILOT
OUR- THEY WERE. THEY WERE
FAMILIES ARE ON THAT ON TRAGIC
FLIGHT AND AS I SAID TO ONE OF
OUR COLLEAGUES MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FROM WHITTIER WHO DECIDED
NOT TO RUN AGAIN BECAUSE OF
FAMILY I TWEETED TM THE-
GREATEST DECISIONI EVER MADE
IN MY LIFE. WAS NOT TO RUN FOR
OFFICE SELECT TO RAISE MY SON
DURING VERY TURBULENT TIME. ANY
LATER ON WENT TO MORE HOUSE GOT
A DEGREE IN BIOLOGY MATHS IS
NOW TEACHING A. L. UNIFIED SO I
KNOW. OUT OF EVERYTHING THAT I
MAY HAVE DONE ON THIS FLOOR
EVERYTHING I MAY HAVE BEEN IN
MY CAREER. THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING THAT I EVER DID. WAS
BEING A FAMILY MAN. AND WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE PEOPLE THERE
ARE ON THIS FLIGHT AND I HEARD
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LAGUNA. GOING
TO BEACH SAY THAT EVEN THE
DEFENSIVE COACH WAS CALLED THE
MOTHER. A DEFENSE WHICH MEANS
YOU HAD A BUNCH OF FAMILY
MEMBERS AND WE ALWAYS HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT PROBABLY THE
GREATEST THING. THAT WE COULD
EVER DO IS BE FAMILY MEMBERS
AND THAT. FLIGHT THE PIT OF MY
AS A NEIGHBOR SAYS EVER COACHED
AND COACHED YOUNG PEOPLE YOU
KNOW THAT YOU ALL BECOME FAMILY
WITH LITTLE LEAGUE WITH THIS
FOOTBALL YOU BECOME EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBERS OF EACH OTHER
AND THAT'S WHAT THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR. TO TAKE ON
THE NEXT GENERATION AND I JUST
FEEL THAT. I WOULD LOVE. I
WOULD LOVE TO SEE KOBE BRYANT
AT THE YUKON GAVE HAVING TO
HAVE TO SIT WHILE HIS DAUGHTER
HAS TO MAKE THAT LAST SECOND
SHOT KNOWING THAT HE CAN'T MAKE
IT BUT HE'S POURED IN ALL THIS
KNOWLEDGE. EVERYTHING INTO THIS
YOUNG GIRL SO THAT SHE COULD BE
THE BEST THAT SHE COULD BE IN
LIFE LIKE ALL THE OTHER PARENTS
THAT WERE ON THAT FLIGHT AND
ALL THE OTHER COACHES THAT OWN
THEIR FLIGHT PORN THE BEST THEY
CAN IN THAT AND SO WHICH WE
LOOK. UPON THAT. WOMEN HAVE A
LOT OF GREAT THINGS THAT
THEY'VE DONE. BUT FOR ME. FOR
ME AS A FAMILY MAN. I THINK
THAT'S THE GREATEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT. THAT EVERYONE
ON THE FLIGHT OF REPRESENTS WE
SHOULD NEVER WE SHOULD NEVER
FORGET THAT WE SHOULD HONOR
THAT. AND TALK ABOUT THAT MORE
MORE MORE TO THE PIT OF MY
SCHOOL WHAT. WE ASPIRE TO.
AGAIN EVERYONE ON A FLIGHT.
WHAT ABOUT. CAN THE NEXT
GENERATION. TO THE NEXT LEVEL
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A
BETTER SOCIETY. AND THE WE
SHOULD CELEBRATE THAT EVERY
DAY- MORE MORE SO EXPECT TO ASK
THAT WOULD JERRY IN THEIR
MEMBERS. THANK YOU RESTAURANTS
WHERE MISTER DAVID CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO ASSOCIATE
MYSELF IN THE COMMENTS IN
TODAY'S IN THE MORNINGS FOR
KOBE BRYANT AND FOR THE VICTIMS
OF THE HELICOPTER CRASH AND I
AM RISING TO SPECIFICALLY
DURING THE MEMORY OF CRISTINA
MOUSER. WHO SERVED ALONGSIDE
KOBE BRYANT AS A TOP ASSISTANT
COACH FOR THEIR GIRLS YOUTH
BASKETBALL TEAM. HER DEPARTURE
HAS DIRECTLY IMPACTED A MEMBER
OF OUR CAPITAL AND A. P. I.
COMMUNITY. MELANIE REMAIN ALL
WHO IS THE CURRENT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF EMERGE CALIFORNIA
AND A FORMER SIMPLY STAFFER.
CRISTINA AND MELANIE WERE
COUSINS. CRISTINA CAME FROM A
HUGE LEVINE FILIPINO FAMILY.
HER MOTHER EMIGRATED TO OUR
COUNTRY FROM THE PHILIPPINES IN
THE NINETEEN SIXTIES. HER
FAMILY AFFECTIONATELY CALLED
HER SIS. AND REMEMBERS HER AS
AN OUTSTANDING ATHLETE SWEET
AND EXTREMELY FUNNY. SHE AND
HER BROTHER WOULD OFTEN PERFORM
SKITS WHERE THEY WORK TO
PERFECT THEIR GRANDMOTHERS
FILIPINO ACCENT. HER PRESENCE
WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED AND OUR
THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE WITH
HER HUSBAND. HER THREE YOUNG
CHILDREN. A THREE YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER A NINE YEAR OLD SON
AND ELEVEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER.
AS WELL SIR EXTENDED FAMILY AN
ASSET YOU JOIN US IN A JOURNEY
IN HER MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHIU MS RUBIO YOUR RECORD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO HONOR
THE VICTIMS OF SUNDAY'S
DEVASTATING HELICOPTER CRASH
AND THE ONE IN PARTICULAR WHEN
SPIRED A TWELVE YEAR OLD BOY
AND AN ELEVEN YEAR OLD GIRL.
KOBE TIGHTEST THAT IN
UNWAVERING WORK ETHIC AND
GENEROSITY ARE ALL IT TAKES TO
MAKE A LEGEND. HAS LEGACY WAS
BIGGER THAN SPORTS HE WAS AN
INTERNATIONAL ICON AND A ROLE
MODEL TO MANY CHILDREN LIKE
MINE. SO ON BEHALF OF MY SON
EATEN. AND MY DAUGHTER NADIA I
WILL LEAVE YOU WITH THIS QUOTE.
LOVE WHAT YOU DO AND IF IT'S
MAKE IF IT MAKES YOU HAPPY. ALL
THE HARD WORK AND PERSEVERANCE
WILL PAY OFF YOU CAN'T STOP
PEOPLE FROM TRYING TO LIMIT
YOUR DREAMS BUT YOU CAN STOP IT
FROM BECOMING A REALITY. YOUR
DREAMS ARE UP TO YOU. THE GAME
IS RUBIO DR CHOI DIRECTNESS.
THANK YOU SPEAKER FOR YOUR
SPECIAL PERMISSION FOR ME TO
SPEAK. I RISE- WITH A VERY
HEAVY HEART. BECAUSE OF OUR
FAMILIES A DEEPER RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE KOBE BRYANT. PEOPLE
MAY NOT KNOW THAT. I AND MY
WIFE FLORA JANIE I PERSONALLY.
TO ORDER. KOBE BRYANT'S
CHILDREN. ONE TIME HE WALKED IN
DOCTOR CHOI I NEED YOUR HELP.
AND JUDY WAS RIGHT THERE AND OF
THIS I CAN OFFER YOU THAT'S ALL
SO ALL. I HELPED HIM AND THE
COFFEE WAS SO SITTING IN FRONT
OF ME. AND THEN. MY WIFE TIPS.
POR PICTURE AND THE MY RIFLE SO
SHORT THE ISSUE YEARS YOUR- AND.
MOTIVATING OR THE CHILDREN WHEN
NEWS DURRANCE COM DO YOU KNOW
THIS. PERSON OF COURSE SO MANY
CHILDREN ON KNOW HIM. OF COURSE
HAS ALL FOR YOU BRIAN WHAT DOES
HE DO HIS- BASKETBALL PLAYER.
NO HE'S HE COULD HOLY S. HIS
HIS GOOD. DO YOU THINK HE
PRACTICES AS PASSPORT OF COURSE
HE DOES. SO YOU MAY BE SO GOOD
IN MATH ABOUT THAT THIS COMMON
PROGRAM THAT THE WE OPERATE THE
WE'RE WE'RE MAKE YOU WILL LIKE
A SUPERSTAR LIKE. KOBE IF YOU
PRACTICE A LOT OF PRACTICE NO
MATTER HOW GOOD YOU ARE. SO ON
KOBE WAS A POSSIBLE WERE. A
EDUCATION PROGRAM AND
MOTIVATING SO MANY CHILDREN.
AND OUR TEACHERS WHO WAS. SENT
TO HIS FAMILY HOME SIGNED A
TOUR OF THE- AND CAN YOU
BELIEVE- HOW DEDICATED THE
FATHER WAS OFF SEASON SO HE
PERSONALLY BROUGHT TO HIS
CHILDREN TWELVE CHATHAM ME. AND
THE PAPER OBVIOUSLY WANNA SEE
HIM. BUT MY WIFE I HAD TO HIDE
HIM SOME HAY IN THE CORNER SO
THAT HE WOULD NOT BE BOTHERED.
BUT THOUGH HE WAS THE ONE
DADDY. GRADING THE PAPER SO
WHICH WE REQUIRE FOR PARENTS TO
BRING. THE CHILDREN'S WORKER TO
BE CHECKED THE BEFORE COMING TO
OUR CENTER. THAT MUCH A HE WAS
A DEDICATED HIMSELF FOR HE WAS
INVOLVED THE- SOUL AMONG MANY
OF THE. THE LEGENDARY STORIES
THAT WE HEAR HOW GOOD PERSON HE
WAS A HOW GOOD IN. A GREAT-
BASKETBALL PLAYER HE WAS. BUT
THE POST IN OUR SIDE OF WITH
THAT KIND OF A STORY SO ON NASA
YOU'LL ENCOUNTER EXPERIENCE
PERSONALLY A MAN ON ALL. SO
THAT'S THE REASON I WANTED TO
SHARE SOME SIDE OF POSSIBLE
FAMILY RELATIONSHIP BY. THAT
THE CONNECTION AND ALL OUR
FAMILY HAS BEEN DEVASTATED TO
WHEN WE LEARNED THAT THE NEW-
SO WHY DID WE ARE SITTING IN
THE- CHURCH SERVICE ON SUNDAY.
I HEY. ASK FOR YOUR- PERMISSION
FOR US TO ALL. HAVE WHILE AT
THE BAR WAS OF HIS FAMILY AND
ON ALSO A JOINT IS. SESSION IN
MEMORY OF WAR OF THE BRIAN AND-
EIGHT OR THE VICTIMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI AND THANK
YOU MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. AT THIS TIME IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED. FOR MANY
MEMBERS PLEASE STAY IN YOUR
SEATS TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR. WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
MS CARILLO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ON THE PREVIOUS
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
NUMBERS TODAY I RISE IN HONOR
OF KOBE BRYANT. I WAS JUST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD WHEN I
GOT MY FIRST BIG BREAK IN RADIO
BROADCASTING. AND HE WAS TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS OLD A MERE TWO
YEARS OLDER THAN ME BUT KOBE
BRYANT WAS ALREADY KING OF LOS
ANGELES. I WAS TO INTERVIEW A
BASKETBALL LEGEND A BRILLIANT
ATHLETE WHO INSPIRED A
GENERATION OF BALL PLAYERS. AND
HE HAD TAKEN ONE OF MY FAVORITE
ARTISTS IN THE LATE NINETIES
BRANDY. TO PROM IT IS SAFE TO
SAY I WAS BEYOND NERVOUS BUT
KOBE WITH THE FLASH OF A SMILE
IN HIS GENTLE AND EASY
MANNERISMS. MADE ME FEEL CALM
SMART. LIKE I MATTERED. I LIKE
MANY OTHERS FOLLOWED HIS CAREER
OUR HOME TEAM. THAT MANY UPS
AND DOWNS AND VICTORIES THAT
SHAPED OUR GREAT CITY AND THE
PEOPLE WHO CALL LOS ANGELES
HOME. AND MANY WAYS THERE IS A
GENERATION OF US WHO FEEL WE
GREW UP WITH KOBE. WHICH IS WHY
IT'S LOS FEELS HEAVY AND
DAUNTING. KOBE'S LEGACY IS HIS
WORK ETHIC HE TAUGHT US THAT IF
YOU WANT SOMETHING HARD ENOUGH
YOU WORK FOR IT. HE SHOWED US
THAT WITH EXTREME FOCUS
CAN'T TAKE ANYTHING ON.
ALTHOUGH KOBE IS REMEMBERED AS
THE BLACK MAMBA A LAKERS LEGEND
WHO WON FIVE NBA CHAMPIONSHIPS
WITH THE TEAM. AND A CHAMPION
TO END HOMELESSNESS THROUGH THE
LOS ANGELES UNITED WAY. IN LA
RE WE REMEMBER HIM AS AN
EXTENSION OF OUR FAMILIES. LIKE
MY OWN FATHER AND MANY OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ON THIS ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. HE WAS A PROUD GIRL THAT.
LET US HONOR HIM HIS THIRTEEN
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER TIANA WHO WAS
CONTINUING HIS LEGACY ON THE
COURT THROUGH THE MAMBA SPORTS
ACADEMY. AND OTHERS WHO PASSED
IN THIS TRAGIC ACCIDENT JOHN A
BELLY CARRIE AND THEIR DAUGHTER
ALYSSA. CHRISTINE AMOUNTS FOR
SERRA CHESTER AND THEIR
DAUGHTER PEYTON CHESTER WHO
ALSO PLAYED A WITH GIGI. AN ERA
SOBRE SUBWAY ON THE PILOT OF
THE HELICOPTER. MAY ALL LIVES
LIVE IN OUR HEARTS FOREVER LET
US AND OUR LOVE AND PRAYERS TO
VANESSA BRYANT. AND HIS THREE
REMAINING DAUGHTERS NATALIA
BIANCA AND CAPRI. AND MAY WE
LIVE OUR LIVES WITH COURAGE AS
WE NEVER KNOW WHEN OUR OWN
FOURTH QUARTER WILL BE UPON US
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS CARILLO
AND THANK YOU MEMBERS. MR
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT'S
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF ALLEN JOSEPH- KASKI WHO DIED
SUDDENLY AND UNEXPECTEDLY
EARLIER THIS MONTH AT THE
TENDER AGE OF FORTY FIVE. HIS
PASSING ALSO SIDES ARE CAPITAL
COMMUNITY AS ALLEN WAS THE
HUSBAND OF CAMERON HER KASKI A
CHIEF OF STAFF IN THE STATE
STATE SENATE FOR SENATOR LEYVA.
ALLEN WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
OUR CAPITAL CITY HE GREW UP AND
HE'S SACRAMENTO ATTENDED
SACRAMENTO HIGH SCHOOL AND
LIVED IN WORK JUST BLOCKS IN
HERE IN THE LAND PARK
NEIGHBORHOOD. AS A SACRAMENTO
KID HE HE KNEW SOMEBODY
EVERYWHERE HE WENT AND HAD
FRIENDS ALL ACROSS OUR CITY. HE
HE WORKED FOR A LONG TIME AS A
LOCAL BARTENDER AT OUR FAMOUS
JAMIE'S BAR AND GRILL. OVER
HERE ON BROADWAY IN THIS
PROFESSION HE WAS A TRUE PEOPLE
PERSON WHO LOVE TO ENGAGE WITH
HIS CUSTOMERS. AFTER HIS
PASSING A FRIEND REMEMBERED
ALLEN AS FOLLOWS I THINK THIS
IS A WONDERFUL TRIBUTE. HE WAS
A WONDERFUL HUMAN BEING FATHER
ROOMMATE AND FRIEND GET A SOFT
HEART CRASS HUMOR RASH
ENLIGHTENMENT DEBONAIR SMILE
AND EXPERTISE AND BARTENDING
HEARD SERVING. AND THOSE WHO
WERE LUCKY LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE
KNOWN HIM ARE BETTER OFF
BECAUSE OF IT. HIS TRAGIC LOSS
REMIND US ALL THAT LIFE IS TOO
SHORT AND WE MUST MAKE THE BEST
OF IT WHILE WE ARE HERE WE CAN.
ALRP SURVIVE. BY HIS AGAIN CAN.
HIS DAUGHTER CAROLINA AND
STEPCHILDREN JOSEPH IN MIAMI.
AND FOR THOSE THAT KNEW ALLEN
IN CAMERON THEY WANTED YOU TO
KNOW THAT MORE A MEMORIAL WILL
HAPPEN LATER IN FEBRUARY. AND
THE DETAILS WILL FOLLOW. AGAIN
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY IN
THE MEMORY OF ALLEN SHOWS THAT-
KASKI. THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY.
AND DOCTOR CHOI YOUR RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS CITY IS WITH YEARS
SOLEMN NEWS THAT I STAND TODAY
TO REQUEST THAT THE WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF- JOAN
IRVINE SMITH. AN AMAZING WOMAN.
HOME HAVE THE OP ALLEGED I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE TO KNOW AND DON'T
WORK WITH THEM DURING MY IS
SERVICE IN IRVINE. ONE PASSED
AWAY THIS PAST A DECEMBER FROM
EXTENDED THE CARDIOVASCULAR IT
IS. A WOMAN F MANY TALENTS SO
JONES WAS. A PHILANTHROPIST
ENVIRONMENTALISTS SOCIAL AND
DAHLE CORPORATE THAT ACTIVIST.
AUSTRIAN AND- CHRONICLER OF A
HISTORY OF US THAT ON
CALIFORNIA. JONES FATHER WAS-
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
IRVINE COMPANY AND THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE OF MIND RANCH
WHICH COVERED THE WEAPONS
SEVENTH OF ORANGE COUNTY.
WITNESSING ORANGE COUNTY GROW
FROM CITRUS GROVES TO IS OUR
CURRENT THREE MILLION OR SO
POPULATION. PRESS THE JONES
INTO ON ON WAVERING AS WILL CUT
FULL CAREFUL WATER PLANNING AND
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OF
SUPERVISION OF LAND THAT
DEVELOPMENT. SHE GAINED THAT
THIS KNOWLEDGE FROM WORKING ON
IRVINE RANCH AND THE BEING
DIRECTOR OF THE BUYING COMPANY.
FROM MARK DONATING LAND OF FROM
THE- FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IRVINE. AND PRESS
PRESERVATION OF. ANY MODEL
HABITAT SO SUCH AS THE CRYSTAL
COVE WAS STATE PARK JORDAN
CHAMPION OF THE CONSERVATION OF
OUR ORANGE COUNTY SO RESOURCES-
AND THE LANDSCAPE. WHILE HER
LIST OF ACCOMPLISHMENTS ARE ARE
MUCH LARGER THAN THE IS. I WILL
STOP HERE. JOAN IRVINE SMITH SO
WILL BE FOREVER REMEMBERED. BY
THE COMMUNITY AYE SHE SIR. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE WE
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI MEMBERS
PLEASE BING THE NAMES OF THE
DENSITY PRINT IN THE JOURNAL
ALL REQUESTS FOR YOUR MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ. IN PRINT
IN THE JOURNAL MEMBERS I HAVE A
REQUEST THAT YOU PLEASE LEAVE
YOUR KEYS IN YOUR TASKS AT THIS
TIME PLEASE LEAVE YOUR KEYS.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED TO RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED. SEEING
HEARING OF FOR THE BUSINESS
ALREADY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN. MR MCCARTY MOVES MR
PEROT SECONDS. THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
FEBRUARY THIRD. AT ONE PM WE
ARE ADJOURNED.
VOTE CHANGE
RAMOS AB SIX FORTY SIX FROM I
TO NOT VOTING THE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX FORTY SIX I IT'S NOT
VOTING.